have you heard of typo squatting well
typo squatting is where companies like
Google post advertisements on websites
that are commonly Mis keyed and then
they sit back and rake in millions
banking on the fact that you're visiting
something like gmail.com or Microsoft
com just seems kind of silly doesn't it
how about this on February 28 an
engineer at Amazon made a similar
seemingly small key err only I say
seemingly small because this one little
typo and Amazon super code produced a
massive internet slowdown that cost the
company over a hundred and sixty million
dollars in the span of just four hours
but this is actually really scary see
recently an employee at the New England
compound which is a pharmaceutical
manufacturer didn't clean the lab
properly and now 76 people have died and
700 more of contracted meningitis I mean
these examples are crazy right when do
we come to live in a world where these
type of typos common errors this do your
best attitude or just good enough was
acceptable at some point we've stopped
valuing perfection and now these are the
type of results that we get you see I
think that we should all seek perfection
all the time and I think we need to get
to it quick you see I run a training
facility where I'm responsible for the
education of professional delivery
drivers and in my line of work we have a
unique understanding with the cost of
failure the cost of just 99% because in
the world of professional driving just
99% on the job means somebody dies look
a hundred people die every day due to
vehicular crashes think about that for a
second that's like the equivalent of for
commercial airliners crashing every week
yet we still can't convince ourselves to
pay perfect attention behind the wheel
so I teach my drivers to value
perfection that's why I have them
memorize our 130 one-word defensive
driving program perfectly and then I
have them rewrite it one wrong word one
misspelled word one missing comma it's a
failed test it's why I do uniform
inspections daily
undershirts are whiter Brown only shoes
are black or brown polished leather and
frankly don't come to my class wrinkled
and expect me to let you stay it's why I
insist that my drivers are on time don't
be late not to class not to brake not to
lunch when you're supposed to be
somewhere be there you see I do this so
that my students understand that when
I'm training them to drive a car and I
say clear every intersection they
understand that I mean every traffic
signal every cross street every side
street every parking lot every dirt road
every crosswalk every intersection
without fail now new students will often
ask me why my class is so difficult
strict or uniform and the answer is
simple you see perfectionism is an
attitude developed into small things and
then applied to the larger job so
basically if you can't get the little
things right you're gonna fail when it
counts and when you're driving a car it
counts a car traveling at 55 miles an
hour covers the length of an American
football field in just under four and a
half seconds it just so happens to be
the same amount of time it takes the
average person to check a text message
so I don't allow my drivers to lose
focus and I don't accept anything less
than perfection out of them and you know
what I'm tired of everybody else
accepting 99% is good enough I mean
being less than perfect has real
consequences doesn't it think about it
if the makers of our credit cards
we're only 99.9% effective there would
be over a million cards in circulation
today that had the wrong information on
the magnetic strip on the back or if the
Webster's dictionary was only 99.9%
accurate it would have 470 misspelled
words in it how about this if our
doctors were only 99.9 percent correct
then every year four million four
hundred and fifty three thousand
prescriptions will be written
incorrectly and probably even scarier
eleven newborns would be given to the
wrong parents every day in the United
States and those are just the odds
the reality is is that the US government
crashed a 1.4 billion dollar aircraft
because the maintenance currently did
99% of their jobs someone forgot to
check a sensor the reality is is that 16
people are now dead 180 have now been
injured and 34 million cars are being
recalled because the producers of a car
airbag produced in distributor product
that they thought was you know it was
good enough the reality is is that
medical errors and now the third leading
cause of death in America 250,000 people
die each year because somebody who
probably thought they were doing their
job good enough messed up and you don't
believe me well I can certainly
understand why you see it's hard for us
to believe anything these days when less
than 50% of what news pundits say is
actually grounded in fact so it comes
down to this trying our best is not good
enough so how do we change we seek
perfection and settle for nothing less
now I know I need to give you a minute
on that because I know what you've been
told right it's probably goes something
like perfection is impossible for humans
so therefore seeking perfection will not
only ruin your self-esteem but it'll
render you a failure but there's the
irony see today we're all so afraid of
that word failure but the truth is we
need to fail failure is a natural
stepping stone towards perfection but at
some point because we can't because we
came so afraid of that idea of failure
and so afraid of that idea of perfection
we dismissed it because of what might
happen to our egos when we fall short I
mean do you really think that failure is
going to ruin you or is that just the
easy answer that gets a slow website
scary healthcare and dangerous roads I
mean are you ready to make perfection
the bad guy in all this
look failure and imperfection are
basically the same thing we all know
that imperfection exists all around us
nothing and nobody is perfect but at
some point because it was too difficult
or too painful we decided to dismiss our
natural ability to deal with failure and
replace it with the lower acceptance
level and now we're all forced to sit
back and just accept this new norm are
good enough attitude and the results
that come with it
so people even with all that said people
will still tell me you know didn't the
medical staff the maintenance crew the
engineer didn't they try their best and
isn't that good enough well truthfully
not for me and especially not in these
examples yeah but you know trying to be
perfect is so stressful right and you
know Oprah talked about it University
study I bet your house high school
counselor even warned you about it
stress is bad for us innit well maybe
but to say that seeking perfection is
too stressful is like saying that
exercise is too exhausting in both cases
if you want the results you got endure
the pain so truthfully saying that
seeking perfection is too stressful is
just an excuse to be lazy but here's the
really scary part today doctors
therapists and the nearly 10 billion
dollar-a-year self-help industry are all
advocating against the idea of
perfection under this guise that somehow
not trying to be perfect will save
yourself esteem and protect your ego but
see it's not working because the
self-help industry today has a high
recidivism rate because it's more
focused on teaching you how to accept
being a failure and lower your
acceptance level that is about pushing
you to be perfect see these doctors
therapists and self-help gurus are all
focused on a symptom and not the illness
the true illness in our society day is
our unwillingness to confront failure
see we're more comfortable resting on
our efforts than we are with focusing on
our results like like a Douglas Rome
High School in Ohio where they named 30%
of a graduating class valedictorian I
mean come on right somebody had the
highest GPA I guarantee you it wasn't a
72 wait i but see we're more comfortable
offering up an equal outcome than we are
with confronting the failure the loser
or the underachiever and when everybody
gets surprised everybody advances or
everybody gets a pay raise despite
results the perfectionist and all of us
is left to wonder what do I have to do
to get better how do I raise above the
crowds and see if we continue to
cultivate this culture where nobody
fails or nobody has told that they will
fail but nobody is going to reach their
potential either failure and
are necessary for success it's the
acceptance of failure that's not
Michelangelo's credit was saying that
the greatest danger for most of us is
not that our aim is too high and we miss
it
but it's too low and we reach it failure
should be a motivating force not some
type of pathetic excuse to give up so I
have an idea instead of defining
perfectionism as a destructive and
tolerance for failure why don't we try
giving it a new definition why don't we
try defining perfectionism as a
willingness to do what is difficult to
achieve what is right you see then we
can agree that failure is a good thing
in our quest for perfection and when we
seek perfection without fear of failure
just think about what we can accomplish
like like NBA superstar Steph Curry he
hit 77 three-point shots in a row think
about that the guy was able to
accurately deliver a nine and a half
inch ball through an 18-inch rim that
suspended ten feet in the air
from nearly 24 feet away almost 80 times
without failure or like the computer
program for programmers at the aerospace
giant Lockheed Martin who have now
written a program that uses 420 thousand
lines of near-flawless code to control
every aspect of igniting four million
pounds of rocket fuel and putting 120
tons spaceship into orbit or maybe like
the researchers at the Children's Mercy
Hospital in Kansas City Missouri who
have now developed a device that can
complete human genome coding in just 26
hours so this device is able to diagnose
genetic diseases in babies and newborns
sooner giving doctors an opportunity to
start treatments earlier and potentially
save the baby's life see that's what
happens when we seek perfection so maybe
we should be more like the professional
athlete or we should be more like that
tireless programmer or like that
passionate researcher then we could stop
fearing failure and we could stop living
in a world filled with the consequences
of good enough thank you
[Applause]